JULIA FERRAIOLI: My
name is Julia Ferraioli
and I am a developer advocate
with Google Cloud Platform.
And today I'm
really excited to be
able to introduce Dan Shapiro,
Founder and CEO of Glowforge,
amongst a number of other
amazing criteria which I'm
sure we will dive into as well.
Oh, and we've got the
nice screen there.
So in addition to being
the CEO of Glowforge,
Dan is also the creator
of Robot Turtles.
Who here has heard of the
board game Robot Turtles?
We've got a few.
I highly recommend
checking it out.
It's an amazing board game
that broke Kickstarter records,
which is fantastic.
DAN SHAPIRO: Back when
the records were lower
a couple years ago.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: You've also
broken some more recent records
than that with Glowforge
breaking crowdfunding history
in 30 days?
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
I think we had the highest
30 day total for anything
Kickstarter,
Indiegogo, et cetera.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Right.
Yes.
OK.
So I want to show you a
brief video about Glowforge.
This is their introduction.
So you can see what
Glowforge is capable of
and how you can
interact with it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Start with the design that
you download or create.
Choose from dozens of materials,
even recycled cardboard.
The laser cuts and
engraves your design.
It's precise to the
width of a human hair
so it's easy to assemble
remarkable things.
Use your Mac, PC, or tablet to
drag your design into place.
Print from organic material,
like wood, leather, paper,
cloth, even chocolate.
Sometimes you don't want
to design from scratch.
Print from the
Glowforge catalog.
You can resize and personalize
to make it perfect for you.
Your design can be
as simple as a photo.
Your favorite apps, like
Photoshop and Illustrator,
can print directly to
create physical objects.
Glowforge cuts holes
with such precision
that you can lace up
leather like a shoe.
If you draw on material
with an ordinary pen,
dual cameras create a 3D
image of your material
and your drawing.
Glowforge will engrave and
cut directly over the ink.
Then it's as easy to
make a dozen copies
as it is to make just one.
Glowforge has auto focus that
can follow curved services
like this MacBook.
Cameras automatically
identify what you put inside,
so it's safe to personalize
your laptop with designs
from the catalog or your
own photos and text.
You can make a daily
essential, a unique gift,
a thriving business, or
you can just make lunch.
You don't have to be a
clothing designer, an artist,
or a pastry chef.
You can build a mansion
without being an architect.
Glowforge is a tool that's
easy enough and safe enough
for anyone to use, unlike this
drone with rubber band gatling
guns.
We've been working hard to
make something amazing for you.
-I'm Dan Shapiro and
this is Glowforge.
Our team has built
everything from cell phones
to search engines, but this,
this is something different.
I have one in my home.
I want you to have one too.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JULIA FERRAIOLI: That's
an amazing video.
And I want some
printed chocolate
because that seems A, like a
really hard problem to solve.
DAN SHAPIRO: It
actually took us a week
of profiling different
chocolates to figure out
exactly the right
blend of chocolates
to make that work, and the
right laser settings, everything
else.
So it was a crazy project.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Wow.
Imagine that it might
try to melt on you.
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
The right trade off between
vaporize it but not melt it.
So you have to cut line
without a big chocolate puddle.
It was a lot of fun.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: And
tasty, I'm assuming.
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
It was actually really nasty
because when we were done
we got tired of
tempering chocolate,
so we went for the
candy chocolate.
It's like low chocolate
content and it's always shiny
and you don't have to go
through the tempering process,
but it's easier to work with.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Easier
to experiment on at least.
DAN SHAPIRO: Movie magic, yes.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Movie magic.
Yes.
So, let's see if we can
get the slides back.
So this is actually one of the
images from Glowforge's home
page.
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
Our firmware engineer
Matt actually
made this for his girlfriend.
I think they met at
Space Needle, had
their first date there.
And so we did this
set of cherry wood.
It's about a quarter inch thick,
just to get a sense for scale.
It doesn't actually
use any glue.
The whole thing snaps together.
And it was so
awesome I asked him
to print a couple extras
so we could use them
as showcase pieces.
But it was just something
he'd done puttering around.
I think he actually
designed it entirely in 2D
and just did the 3D in his
head rather than doing it CAD,
but it was kind of a neat piece.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
And it's interesting
because I know from
my limited experience
watching old episodes of
"This Old House," having
the ability to make
tight connections
without different materials
to glue it together
or to secure it
together produces
a much more solid piece
that's less prone to breakages
as well.
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
One of the early
design questions
was how do we take the
consistent behavior
of the laser, which
is very esoteric
and has lots of edge
cases, but it pretty much
operates the same
way every time,
and use that to produce
predictable prints every time.
And that was ultimately the
thought process that led us to,
hey, we want to apply
really large scale computing
resources to the problem.
We don't want a
little firmware that's
taking G-code, which is kind of
the low-level language invented
in the 50s or 60s for
running milling machines,
and running that.
We actually want to have a
very high level of abstraction
of the material, of the laser,
of the manufacturing process
so we can produce really
replicable results.
And we didn't think we could do
that cost effectively running
on the machine, which ultimately
led to the whole let's
put all the brains
in the cloud and make
the machine as simple and
straightforward as possible.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So can
you describe a little bit
about what happens
in the software
besides the hardware itself?
Like what else is there?
There's the Glowforge,
there's the ability
to transfer images
to the Glowforge.
What else happens in the cloud?
DAN SHAPIRO: So the way
the architecture works
is that the user interface
is through a browser,
it's a browser-based
application.
And you can use your iPad,
you can use your computer.
There's no reason you
can't use a phone,
although we haven't phone
optimized the UI yet.
And so it starts out--
actually when you first
plug in the machine you're
going to connect to it locally
over a Wi-Fi access
point that it broadcasts
and configure it because it's
got one button and no screen.
So you're going to connect up
to it like a Nest thermostat
or a Dropcam, but no screen.
So you connect up to it.
You get it on your
home or office Wi-Fi.
That point, you can
log in from a browser
and you can see the machine.
You can pair it
with your account.
And from then on, that's how
you're interacting with it.
So I'll give you a really
straightforward example,
something we do
all the time, which
is you might go into Adobe
Illustrator or any other design
software, create software-- with
Illustrator there's a plugin,
otherwise you can use
a PDF-- and you're
going to take the output
of that and push it
to our cloud service.
Pulls up a web page
and then you're
going to see a real live
preview of the actual bed
of the machine.
Put a piece of material in
there-- could be leather,
could be wood, it could
be seaweed or chocolate.
Put something in
there and it will
have its own unique
characters and imperfections.
And you can actually
drag around your design
to figure out where
it's going to go.
And this is all being done
locally in the browser.
So the browser app is
manipulating basically an SVG
in real time, superimposed
on top of the bitmap that's
pulled over from the device.
Then you say OK, go, and it
sends that up to the server.
The server actually
goes and does
a whole bunch of work
manipulating the SVG
into its final form,
and then doing things
like figuring out what's
the motion plan, where
does the head of
the laser need to go
at what time, what speeds.
It knows the acceleration
parameters of the laser
so it knows how fast it can
go, how fast it can accelerate,
decelerate, when to turn
it on, when to turn it off.
And it winds up with the
simplest possible format,
which is basically
a pulse file--
1's and 0's-- compresses
them, and then sends that down
to the machine.
And the Glowforge's job is just
to decompress that and feed it
out in real time to the
motors, and to the lasers,
and to the fans, and everything
else, all the onboard systems.
But the goal is to make
the firmware on the machine
incredibly simple.
So it does run Linux.
It's a fairly standard
stripped down distro.
But we want to update the
firmware as infrequently as
possible, because
every time you update
the firmware on a machine
there's risk of breaking,
and risk of everything else.
So we want to be able to
innovate in the motion plan,
in the UI, in the
design, and all
that from the speed of
software up in the cloud
rather than having to
do it in the firmware.
So on the back end we're
running Google Compute Cloud,
we're using Docker containers
for all the various components.
Not using Kubernetes yet,
although one of our investors,
Joe Beda, one of the
creators of Kubernetes,
is helping us get that up
to speed before we ship
for maintaining containers.
And all the designs are
in Google Cloud Storage.
I'm trying to think if there's
anything else particularly
interesting about that.
So yeah, every
machine is basically
connected up to the cloud.
Every user's connecting
up through a client.
And our goal is always to do as
much on the server as we can.
And the stuff that's
down on the machine
is basically either
the offline set up,
the updater for the firmware,
and the hard real time stuff,
and that's it.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So putting
the brains of the operation
into the cloud allows
you to ship the product
but continually offer
improvements and new features
and flexibility.
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
I've said half seriously the
only thing we have to get right
in the firmware is the updater.
Like if we can ship with a
functioning firmware updater
then all of their
problems are solvable.
But by pulling as much of that
as possible into the cloud,
it lets us do stuff,
and cool stuff.
Like, for example, let's say
we discover a common problem
with all the existing lasers.
So we've figured
out how to solve
it is if you're drawing a
square you have to slow down
for the corners because you've
got physics to deal with.
You have to decelerate
and then start up again.
And you wind up having a
little hole in the corner where
the laser does a nice-- if
you're just trying to engrave--
just does a nice
light engraving,
but then it slows down, stops,
and so you wind up with a hole.
So let's say that we
have a change that says,
OK, we're going to
decrease the power as you
approach the corner.
We want to push that out.
There's a couple of interesting
problems with doing that,
typically.
One is when do you push that?
How do you get that update out?
There are people who are
in the middle of printing.
You want to test
that with those.
So given this architecture
we can say, OK, first
we're pushing it out to people
who've signed up for beta.
Then we're going to
push it out to 1%
and we're going to
wait a couple days
and see if we get
any complaints.
Then we're going to
push it out to 50%.
Then we're going
to do A/B testing
and see user
satisfaction results.
Then we're going to
push it out to everybody
who is not in the middle
of an active print.
Right?
Because at any given time
there are some people who
are actually using the thing.
And then finally we'll
push it out to everybody,
but we'll let you keep
the old motion planning
algorithm if you
like its results
and don't want to change it.
We can leave that
around indefinitely
and have it run side by
side with the new one.
That's a level of
flexibility that's
just never before possible
on this sort of machinery,
where you're pushing
like a PC client app,
because most lasers run
Windows XP, Windows 7 if you're
lucky-- like local
client apps, or it's just
in the firmware of
the machine and you're
hoping people push
your firmware update.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So let's
go back a little bit.
What made you realize
that, hey, lasers
are a good place
for some innovation.
What drew you to lasers
in the first place?
DAN SHAPIRO: So it was this
weird line starting in college
when I built laser shows and
put myself through college doing
laser shows at parties.
And it was a weird
little DJ business
at Harvey Mudd, where
I went to school.
But set all that
aside for a long time
and did a bunch of
software startups,
worked at Google,
worked at Microsoft.
And then took a leave of
absence when I was at Google
and wound up creating
this board game.
And a friend of mine said,
boy, my son loves the turtles.
And he carried the turtle in
his pocket for like three days
before it got so grimy.
And it's cardboard, right.
And it was like
a total disaster.
He's like, you should
sell a super premium
version of the game
where you actually
have dimensional turtles that
my kid can shove in his pocket.
And I was like all right.
Turtles you can
shove in your pocket.
That sounds like a fun thing.
I always wanted to
want a 3D printer
but I could never figure
out what I wanted one for.
And so I was like, as
soon as I figure out
one thing I'm going to
do with a 3D printer,
I'm going to go to the
MakerSpace and do it.
And if I can figure
out three things,
I'm going to buy a 3D printer.
So I had my first ever thing
to do with a 3D printer.
So I went to the
local MakerSpace
and I got this stringy blob of
plastic and I paid $20 for it.
I was like, this stinks.
And so I looked at SLA
and different technologies
for 3D printing and
they were brittle,
and it was all
really frustrating.
So I went back to the same
friend who actually works
at a shop that does custom
fabrication for Boeing
and I said tell me every
machine you have in the shop.
What can I make these
damn turtles out of?
So we went through the whole
thing, and at some point
he mentioned lasers.
I said oh, you
know, like the game.
In the game the turtles
have lasers on their backs.
It'd be cool if I had a
special laser edition.
And also it would be really
awesome to have an excuse
to go buy a laser.
So one thing led
to another and I've
got this $11,000 industrial
carbon dioxide cutting
laser installed in my garage.
I should mention I have
a very patient wife.
And it was like this core
of utter magic surrounded
by layers and layers
of horribleness.
I have to give you
but one example.
After spending days getting
it aligned and configured
and everything else
I'm on the phone
because I'm just trying to
cut a line, the simplest
thing possible, right?
And it's crashing every single
time I send it to the laser.
And so I talk to the importers.
I try to talk to
the manufacturers.
And it turns out that
the software actually
comes from Boston.
And so I talked to
the team in Boston
and I get escalated to the
engineer who wrote the code.
And he says, wait, what
are you trying to draw?
And I'm like, a horizontal line.
He's like, so you mean
like y equals zero?
And I'm like, yeah.
He's like, oh, I'm dividing by
the height, sorry about that.
Nobody had ever tried to
draw a line before on laser.
So it was designed for small
scale factory production
where people would spend a
long time creating a design,
getting everything to work, and
then you'd just crank out one
after another.
But once you did, the
products were beautiful.
They're actually made out
of materials that you want
and that you could use.
And it was fast.
And once you had it working,
iteration was really easy.
So it felt like there was
this beautiful core surrounded
by all this terribleness.
So that's when I started
talking to some friends who
were entrepreneurs and one who
had a design background, one
who had a hardware
background, and said,
could we pair up this core of
lasers that can cut and engrave
things with modern sensor
technology out of-- I
said let's imagine everything in
a two-year-old iPhone is free.
Every part on a
two-year-old iPhone is free.
So we got all the microphones
and accelerometers
and cameras we want for
approximately zero cost.
What could we take out
of the bill of materials
of a traditional laser, how
could we make it even better?
And that's when we
started to come up
with all sorts of crazy things.
Like, as an example,
there's an assembly
in every laser on
the market and it
deals with how you
align your drawing
relative to your material.
Because lasers are very
precise relative to itself,
but you're putting it
on a piece of leather
or a piece of cardboard,
which is just somewhere
sitting on the bed.
And the traditional
way to do that
is with a little
tiny laser pointer
that is a secondary laser with
this complex optical system
to have it go exactly where
the real laser is going to go.
And then you tell the laser
to draw an outline of what
it's going to do,
and it's difficult.
It adds hundreds of
dollars worth of cost.
And it means you actually
have an exposed laser
beam that the user could reflect
into their eyeballs, which
means that it's less safe
than if it was all interlocked
and put away.
In technical terms, it's a Class
III device instead of a Class I
device, like your DVD player.
And we said, well, what if
we just got rid of all that
and had a camera, and
you just drag the thing
to where you want it to go,
and then you could see it?
And that costs us
less, it's easier
to use, and so on and so forth.
So that notion of like, hey,
if we brought this into today
and moved all the
brains off board,
put low-cost sensors on
instead of high-cost optics
and mechanical units,
what could we do?
That was the birth of
where it all started.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
So did the people
who were working on lasers
up to that point just not
consider these options?
Were they really building
it more for industrial use
than bringing it to
the personal use?
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
I mean there's wonderful
devices out there.
Companies like Universal
and Epilog make these tanks,
they're made out of solid metal.
The lasers themselves
are solid laser tubes.
They are designed
to last for decades,
and they do last for decades.
Like if you go onto
eBay, you will not
see a used one of these
for less than $15,000
because it doesn't
matter if they're used.
They're just kind of the same.
And every six years you pay 5
to 7 grand to recharge the tube
and you're off again.
You've got a service person who
comes in and oils everything.
And that's been the
market up till now.
And so to go in
there and say, hey,
what if the market for this was
people who buy amazing sewing
machines?
What if the market for
this was the people
who are buying vinyl
cutters and scrapbooking?
What if the market for this is
people who are buying MakerBots
for their shop, or
for their school,
or for their MakerSpace?
What if that was the
market instead of people
who are cutting and engraving
things for their business?
P.S. also them too, but
at the smaller scale
and at the lower end.
Because it's a lower power
laser on this scale and that
means it's not as fast as the
100-watt or 200-watt laser
that you can get from some
of the larger companies.
How big would that market be?
And it's been really gratifying
to see that, yeah, this
is something people
do get excited about
and do want for themselves.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: And
in fact, I believe
you crossed-- was it 20?
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah, it was
$27.9 million after 30 days.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: In pre-orders.
DAN SHAPIRO: It was a
bit of a surprise to us.
We sat down and when we
were doing our planning,
we're like, OK,
time to place bets.
And so I sat down with my
exec team and our board member
Brad Feld from Foundry Group.
And so we all sort of took bets.
And then we said, OK,
and what's the top end?
And the most funded 3D printer
today had raised $3.5 million
in a 30-day period.
And so we decided $5 million
was our oh my gosh, maybe
we could do it.
And it's just been
incredible, way
beyond anything we'd expected.
And it really puts a lot on
us in a very positive way,
but also it's something we
think about seriously when
we come in every day.
If you go to
community.glowforge.com,
only people who've
ordered can post there.
Anybody can read it.
And there's this really
humbling conversation
where somebody says this is the
car I sold to buy my Glowforge.
And somebody said,
oh yeah, me too.
This is the car I
sold to buy Glowforge.
And somebody else said, I took
out a loan against my 401(k).
And somebody else
said, I've already
let my boss know that
I'm going to give notice
when I get this so I can
go and start my company.
And when we come
into work every day,
that's what we're
thinking about,
which is that we owe
these people something.
They paid for it and we
need to deliver it to them,
and it needs to be even
better than we promised
because they are
going to be changing
their livelihoods around this.
And that's one of the tremendous
challenges of creating hardware
is that people can see
it before it exists,
people can imagine
and people will
change their lives
around what you promise them.
And so being able to
deliver on those promises
is pretty humbling.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: That's
a huge responsibility.
And that must make you take the
community aspect of Glowforge
incredibly seriously as well.
What do you envision for
how the community interacts
with each other once Glowforge
ships and people start
making things?
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
One of the things that was
important to us from the start
was to think about the
software side of it every bit
as much as the
hardware side of it.
And it's easy to get really
focused on the hardware
because we need to ship
a large box of laser
to a whole lot of
people really soon.
But in the longer term,
we think the value of this
is unlocked by the
software that we build,
and that is just a tool for
building a community around it.
So beyond the
here's the interface
and here's how it
works, it's this notion
of how do people share designs?
How do people monetize
their designs?
At the same time,
how do we make this
a place where creative
people can build a business
and how do we embrace
and not commodify
the design and creativity
that comes out of these?
Because ultimately we
think this is a way
that people can go
and take their ideas
and turn them into
businesses, whether it
be a board game, or a wallet,
or a piece of artwork.
And creating an
environment that's warm
and welcoming to that while
at the same time respecting
people's IP.
If you've been to
Thingiverse, which
is MakerBot's open location,
you can download products--
there are some premium
products that you
pay for-- but there's
a whole lot of the,
I call it, skin my
elbow phenomenon.
Which is, hey, look,
I just got a connect
and I 3D scan my
elbow, and here it
is because you can
upload anything there.
And it's not a great
place for designers
and for creative people
to show their best work,
and it's really hard,
bordering on impossible,
to build a business around
it because it's just
kind of a big repository.
So figuring out how do
we build a community that
values that that
creates and contributes,
build a premium experience
where people can go
and make a living off of
selling their digital designs,
and at the same time empower
people to go and just
share freely for those
people who want to do so,
that's been a real
ongoing challenge
as we think about building the
ecosystem around the hardware
that we're creating.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Right.
And when I think about the
potential for people showing
their designs,
obviously it has a lot
of the questions surrounding IP.
And I'm seeing the idea
of public domain images
that people can base ideas off
of getting a lot more popular.
So they can fork,
and modify, and then
use their Glowforge on.
So it's been really interesting.
It's an interesting journey
to have seen take place.
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah, we
have a discussion thread
where I basically said, hey,
how do you want this to work?
And it was so far from
having a singular answer.
There were people who
said I want an FTP
site where I can put any file
in and anybody else can get it.
And there are people who
say I want a completely
locked down experience
where everything I
put in there is
DRMed and tracked,
and pay per this and
that and everything else,
and everywhere in between.
And so figuring out
the right solution
to accommodate everybody
is going to be something--
we're going to iterate
towards that after we ship.
But I think that's a
really important part
of any modern piece of
hardware, which is the value
so often comes from the
software that plugs into it
rather than just
the hardware itself,
figuring out how to create that
ecosystem so that it supports
rather than undermining
what you're trying
to build with the product.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: You're
trying to build up
the community rather than
kind of regulated way.
DAN SHAPIRO: Exactly.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Yeah.
Awesome.
So I want to switch
tracks a little bit
and touch on how this
was really made possible.
You have kind of an interesting
history with crowdfunding.
And coming from one of the
questions on the internet,
from Twitter and from the
Google forum for the longer form
questions, was based
from a position
that you stated in your
book "Hot Seat," which
is the guide to CEO-hood, which
is an amazing and humbling book
to read.
But in there you stated
that you were kind of
wary of crowdfunding at first.
How did you grow to
encompass it in such
a phenomenally successful way?
DAN SHAPIRO: So it started out
in Kickstarter's early days.
And a friend of mine, Elan
Lee-- he's, for those of you
who played the game
Exploding Kittens,
he's the creator of
and won a couple of Emmy
awards for TV shows.
And he's this
amazing, creative guy.
And he's like, Dan, I got this
amazing thing on Kickstarter.
It's so great.
I was like, tell me about
this Kickstarter thing.
And he's like, well,
you give them money
and then maybe later
they send you something.
And I was like, you get equity?
No.
But they don't have
to deliver anything?
No, no.
The terms and services
are very clear.
Terms and conditions
They don't actually have
to send you anything.
I'm like, so it's charity?
Like I just did not understand
at all what this was about.
And he was really excited.
I remember the thing
he told me about
was a fish tank for jellyfish.
So it was a unique
lucite beautiful thing,
since been called
the-- what was it
called-- the whining jellyfish
death trap because apparently
it's a better meat
grinder for jellyfish
than it is a habitat
for them, and it just
kills anything you put in it.
So it turned out it did
ship close to on time,
but was just an utter failure
from a product quality
standpoint.
He'd backed dozens
of Kickstarters.
And I was just looking at
this going I don't even
understand what this is about.
So he'd been working
on a TV show that
had some relationship
to Kickstarter
and I was helping with him.
And I had this like, OK, I have
to wrap my head around this.
So I went and just
pledged a dollar
to a bunch of
Kickstarters so I would
start getting their updates.
And then I was like, oh,
this is kind of cool.
And I kind of want something.
OK, so I pledged some money
to a couple Kickstarters.
And actually, coincidentally,
as it happens,
this hoodie was a Kickstarter
from some people who
wanted to start up a clothing
studio in Los Angeles
and bring back some of
the handmade quality.
And I will say right now their
ship is called Pistol Lake.
They're shipping
amazing clothing.
This one, which is one of the
first ones off their lines,
has a few frays and
some of the stitching
didn't quite work out, but
they got it all sorted out.
And so it kind of changed
the way I think about it.
Very cynically, it's
a legitimization
of vaporware, which has
been going on forever,
but sort of in a good way
in that you're putting
all your cards on the table.
You're saying, look, you
used to pay for stuff
because we lied to you
and told you it was ready.
No, no.
Now we're actually telling
you exactly where it's at,
exactly what you'd get.
You're going to be paying
usually a better price for it
than you would otherwise.
You're going to get it when
it's ready, which we expect
is going to be on this date.
I think more optimistically
it's this notion of involving
your customers in your
development process, which
from the standpoint of
a creator is magical.
You get the funds to
go deliver the product.
But 10 times more
than that, you get
to find out if people love and
care about what you're doing,
and you actually get
their participation
in the creative process.
So the Glowforge is going to
be a 10x better product for all
the feedback that we've gotten
from our users over the course.
Now it's interesting,
because it's hardware.
We had to make and lock most
of the hardware decisions
up front before the
crowdfunding campaign.
But we can do so much
in the software based
on what we've heard that at
launch our software is going
to be far better than it
would have been otherwise,
and it will continue
to improve with that.
So it means you get
the dollars that you
can go into production.
There's two real costs to
starting a hardware company.
There's all the
infrastructure, there's
the rent and salaries
and everything else,
and then there's the
actual manufacturing costs.
And I'd say that best
practices for crowdfunding
are that you use
the dollars you get
from the crowdfunding for
manufacturing and production.
And if you're paying yourself a
salary, if you're paying rent,
you get those dollars
from somewhere else,
from your savings,
or from investors,
or something like that.
But there's some campaigns
that are very upfront as well.
And they'll say I am
raising $50,000 so
that I can pay myself to
spend the next year of my life
developing this
software, or I'm going
spend some of this on the
hardware and deliver and some
of this on rent and
R&D, or whatever else.
At the end of the day, I
think any creator who's
honest with their backers
about where they're at
and what they're doing
is doing it well.
The place where I think
we've gotten into trouble
is there's a little bit of
malice, where you see people
who are actually trying to
fleece their backers and just
mislead folks and
take the money,
saying x is done
when it's not done,
or having no
intention of doing it,
or saying they're
developing something
but really they're
just repackaging
something somebody else made.
But that's dwarfed by just
boundless optimism and people
who are creating projects
without really understanding
what they're committing
to, without really thinking
through the financial
repercussions of what they're
doing.
All that said, if you are
creating a product where
you have clarity about
what you need to do,
where you can communicate
that, boy, it's
hard to argue against talking
to your customers first.
And it's hard to argue that you
should hold off putting it out
for sale when in fact
there are people out there
who are willing to buy
it before it's finished.
And as long as you're
honest and transparent
about that as a business,
I think that it's all
good for all parties involved.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Absolutely.
And as you said, it
gets potential customers
involved earlier.
And I think it also helps people
conquer that little bit of fear
that says, oh, as I'm going
through and building a product,
what if people don't like it?
We can find out early and often.
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
And that fear, it's
not just self-doubt.
It is actually the existential
question of a company.
Like am I doing something
people care about?
And it is remarkably
easy to delude yourself
about where that goes.
I will say that both for Robot
Turtles and Glowforge forge,
I came out happily on
the right side of it.
In neither case did I know that
it was going to be a success.
With Glowforge, we did
enough market research
that we had a pretty
good idea that we
were going to get to half
a million to a million
and felt good about that.
With Robot Turtles,
I thought 50-50
it just wasn't going to fund.
Like I trying to raise 25K and
I know there's a good chance
nobody would notice
and nobody would care.
And that actually would have
been a much better outcome
than the alternative that was
available five years before,
which is to spend a year of your
life, go through manufacturing,
tens of thousands of
dollars to populate
your garage with a
bunch of cardboard boxes
that nobody cared about.
That was the world
before crowdfunding
and it's a much
better world now,
where it may be disappointing if
what you find doesn't catch on
but you have permission
to go back and try again.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Right.
Absolutely.
So another question
from the internet,
the internet at large, was
about the idea of kind of best
practices and crowdfunding.
I know we've talked about the
clarity, the transparency,
the early engagement.
This question was specifically
around offering discounts
of your hardware or your
software product, let's say.
And what are your thoughts
and advice for anybody
who's considering going
the crowdfunding route?
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
It's challenging to be
transparent about pricing
only because you never
know what's in the future.
Like we know what our
manufacturer suggested
retail pricing is for Glowforge,
which is the amount that we--
so we have a pretty good sense
of what we'll wholesale it for
and there's this MSRP
which is hey, retailer,
this is what we think you should
sell it for but then people
can do whatever they want.
And there's been cases
where-- I know of one case
where a crowdfunding campaign
sold it for x, sold it
at wholesale for x, and then the
retailer discounted it below x.
This is a loss leader.
Now, if Target wants
to do a loss leader,
or Macy's, or whatever,
that's their right.
And in fact, federal law
prevents a manufacturer
from saying you must
sell it at this amount.
But for the backers of
the campaign, that stinks.
By going through
that process and then
coming out on the other
side and finding out
that people who came
later paid less.
But it's always
really tough to tell.
So I'll take Robot
Turtles as an example.
So I was selling it for--
the crowd funding campaign,
it was I think $30.
And when the crowdfunding
campaign was done
I was selling it for $40.
And for six months people
were selling it for $40.
And then I actually licensed the
manufacturing rights to a board
game manufacturer and
they got the price
down to $25, which is great for
the world at large who now has
access to this game for less.
I didn't feel terrible
about it because I'd
told my backers up front
that that might happen,
and because they'd had access to
it a year before anybody else.
And it was a different edition.
When they started manufacturing
bulk it was somewhat different.
But again, it comes back
to that transparency,
not making promises
you can't fulfill.
I think you want to try and
give the crowdfunding backers
the best value you can.
But at the same time, the
flip side of that mistake
is you see companies that sell
at such an unrealistically
low price they put
themselves out of business.
And there have
been a lot of cases
of that, where they just don't
raise enough money to fulfill
their project.
Or they wind up having
to double or triple
the price of the product
after the crowdfunding
campaign, which sort of
feels good for the backers
but may mean that a project
that looked viable at one price
isn't viable when you've
tripled the price.
And so they wind up going out
of business because now they
have to charge too much.
So at the end of the
day, all you can do
is try and give the best
value you can to your backers
and be transparent about
what might happen next.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Right.
Those are good
guiding principles.
Now, you've done
the startup a couple
of times, a few times now.
Right?
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
And you've also,
as you mentioned,
worked at Google,
you've been at Microsoft.
And I imagine there
might be some people here
that are looking to either make
a switch one way or another.
What advice do you have
them from your experience
in industry?
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
I'd say it's been about
a little less than half
of my working life at a
big company, a little more
than half at a small.
The first five years I worked at
Microsoft as a program manager.
And then I went to a startup.
Now I say I went to a startup.
I didn't start a startup.
Actually, I did.
When I was working
at Microsoft I
had this great idea for
a startup, I thought.
It was a terrible idea.
It crashed and burned.
I was depressed and
couldn't figure out
what to do with
myself for six months.
It was one of the most horrible
experiences of my life.
And worked at Microsoft
for a couple more years.
And then went to go work
at a friend's startup.
And it was amazing because I
learned about all my mistakes
on somebody else's dime.
That was where I got
my startup degree.
And not just that,
but that's where
I met people who I've
worked with ever since.
That's where I met
investors who actually
had some experience
with me and where
I could build a
network of people
who I could raise funds from.
That experience of going
to work at a startup
was the best training I
could have possibly had
before starting my own company.
And really, that's what
I'd recommend to anyone.
Now there's some
real culture shock
around it and some huge change.
Oftentimes you're taking
a pay cut, depending
how early the startup is.
That could be anywhere
from 30% to 100%.
And the environment
is very different.
There's this
realignment where some
of the skills that made you
very successful at a big company
may in fact contribute to your
failure at a small company.
For example, being able
to manage a bureaucracy
effectively is a core skill if
you're at Google, or Microsoft,
or any large company.
And that's not a
negative thing, it's
that there are these
huge agglomerations
of people who all have
different motives, and agendas,
and directions
managing your career.
So regularly helping
everybody understand
where you're at,
what you're doing,
what value you're providing.
But in a small company you
create value for yourself
by making the company valuable.
The earliest Google
employees, it
doesn't matter what they did
while they were there early.
They're perceived to be valuable
because they helped make Google
valuable in those early days.
Same is true of every
other successful company
at the start.
So it has so much more to do
with the output of the company
than it does with your
particular contribution.
And that just changes the way
you go into work every day.
You go into work every day
thinking where are we going
and how do we get there rather
than what's expected of me
and how do I deliver
on that today.
And neither one is
right nor wrong.
Some people love
both, but some people
have a strong preference
towards one or the other.
It's much better to figure
that out as an employee,
where if you change
your mind you
can fix that, than as a founder
where if you change your mind
you're abandoning people
who are depending on you.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Right.
Absolutely.
And so given all of
that experience and now
you're starting another company.
DAN SHAPIRO: Once again.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Once again.
What have been some of the
guiding principles that have
come out of your experience?
What has backed your
company and made
it the strong
community that it is?
DAN SHAPIRO: One of the really
transformational experiences
I had was the second
startup I had.
It's a company called Sparkbuy.
It was comparison shopping
for consumer electronics.
So it was on the back end that
nobody saw and nobody even
knew existed.
It was hundreds of people
in emerging markets who
are manually
scouring spec sheets,
calling manufacturers,
and inputting data
about every piece of consumer
electronics on the market.
And then on the front
end it was a really
simple and straightforward
UI that you
could say I want a big
TV that can accommodate
my N64 and my PS3, and has
an HDMI 60 hertz input,
or whatever it is.
Or I want a fast
red Sony laptop.
And it could understand
those things,
translate them into
quantitative measures,
and bring up the
best products first.
That company existed for six
months before it sold to Google
and that's how I
wound up at Google.
But we had this experience
that was just transformational
there.
We were debating between
building first for mobile
and building first for the web.
And I had this idea
that I wanted to try
and it was ultimately why
we built first for the web.
What I wanted to do was to
run usability tests every day
on the build of the day.
This was the crazy idea.
Every day we'd check in code.
Every night we'd
have people use it.
And every morning we'd
see what happened.
And so Scott, my chief
architect there and now
chief architect
again at Glowforge,
thought it was a little
crazy when I was like,
guess what, we're going
to have five people use
that code we just checked
in the first time we did it.
We pushed it out to
a staging server.
I went to MTurk and I
recruited five people
to go use the software.
And the deal was they were going
to turn on their microphone,
turn on screen capture, upload a
video to YouTube of them trying
to research a laptop.
And so we came in the
next morning, we sat down.
Actually, it was lunch
we decided to do this.
So I had this vision
in my head of Scott
with his burrito in hand,
took a bite, I hit play,
and he stops chewing with a
mouthful burrito and stares
in horror.
We had this huge list of bugs.
They were like oh, if you
pick these two filters then
things will crash.
And this filter isn't working
properly, and everything else.
And they were just
clicking on something
they thought was a button
and wasn't a button
and were getting
progressively more frustrated.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
There are some people
who identify with this
feeling in the audience.
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
And/or going like oh no.
And then they're going in and
there was some other problem
where like there
was a slider and it
didn't look like a slider.
And so they're trying
to click the slider
and it was a drag slider.
And he just quietly
set down the burrito
and pulled up his laptop and
no lunch was eaten that day.
It was so embarrassing.
And the worst part
was we'd already
committed that we were going
to push again and run five more
tests that night.
And we felt so horrible
watching our users
suffer through our
incompetence that it did more
to motivate the
development of that product
and motivate the development of
the product in the right way.
Not when you click
these three things
and move the slider
to the right,
the server crashes, which
to us seems like the worst
thing on the planet, but
that looks like a button
and it's not a button so
they're stabbing their finger
in increasing frustration.
Server crashes, UI freezes,
they're going to be annoyed,
they're going to leave
and not come back.
But they have rightfully
left you behind.
This was just
torturing our users,
and that's what we were doing.
And so we had our
bug database and it
was full of all this
stuff we needed to fix
and we wound up basically
completely ignoring all that
and developing and fixing
bugs entirely based
on what we found everyday
users were telling us.
And that was completely
transformational.
It was the first time
that I had really
moved in the most
dramatic way possible
from we're going to
build everything we can
and design everything we
can, and we will push,
and we'll accept bug
reports, and then
we'll look at those, interact
with them, to like we're just
going to sit here
with our ears open
and you're going to tell
us how stupid we are.
We're going to listen and
we're going to try and get
better, and try to get better.
And at some point
we'll be caught up
to the point where our
product doesn't suck horribly.
And then we've earned
the right to go innovate
and to go try things
out and be like,
no, no, we think
there's something
here that you didn't
ask for but that's
going to make your life better.
But until we've
earned that right,
we need to just sit
there and listen.
And so Glowforge is challenging
because with hardware you have
to do a lot of that up front.
But a core part of
the Glowforge design
was make ourselves as
responsible as possible,
both in terms of how
we run the company
and in terms of how we architect
the platform, allow ourselves
to be that responsive to
the users that we have.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: The
flexibility that you get.
No, that makes a ton of sense.
So let's switch a little bit
to the personal fabrication
side of it.
Now, the audience
has heard a lot
about ubiquitous computing--
signed up for this conference.
And they've got a day and a
half so far of great talks
about ubiquitous computing.
You actually place
Glowforge more in the realm
of personal fabrication, right?
So what do you mean
by that and what
excites you about the potential
in this emerging area?
DAN SHAPIRO: I think
there's two approaches
and they're both interesting.
One is we have this
sensor package,
we have cloud storage,
what can it do?
The other is we have this old
machine that does one thing
and does it well, what could
it do if we hooked it up
to the wider world?
And they both can
produce amazing results
and they can both produce
comically ridiculous mash ups
of the internet and hardware.
And where you land
ultimately is up to customers
to tell you about that.
This started out very much
from the standpoint of we
think that there is something
wonderful in the world that
isn't accessible to
most of the people who
would benefit from it.
And how can we go use the
power of ubiquitous computing
of cloud services,
of low-cost sensors
to go bring that
value to everybody?
This is a very common trend.
So the 3D printer
revolution started--
most people don't know-- but
3D printers have been around
for decades.
They're just giant
industrial machines
that cost a quarter
of a million dollars
and were totally inaccessible
to the home user.
And it was only with the
expiration of the first patents
around-- FDM I think it is, the
little, tiny hot glue guns that
build stuff up, like a
MakerBot-- with the expiration
of those patents that you could
actually go build a desktop 3D
printer and go drive
the price down.
And that's what created the
first 3D printing revolution.
Now, most of the core
patents around lasers
expired decades ago, because
the heyday of development
was really around the 80s.
But what kept it from
getting to people
was-- it was really two things.
It was all the support
systems required.
Like the very lowest cost
motion planners you can buy.
The motion planner
takes G-code via USB
from your computer, the
low-level language describing
where it should move,
turns it into pulse files,
is on the order
of $600 wholesale.
So slap that on top
of whatever cost
you're paying already for it.
So the cost of these support
components was enormous.
And ironically the
actual laser parts
were reasonably
commodified because they're
used enough in other things
that those weren't so expensive.
It was the boards
that were created only
for laser cutters,
which ties right
into the second part, which
was the market was tiny.
And part of the reason
the market was tiny
was because everybody
knew the market was tiny.
And it's hard to grow a market
when everybody has for decades
seen that as best I can tell the
analysts say there's something
on the order of $110 million a
year worth of CNC laser cutter
engravers under a kilowatt sold.
And that's just not
big enough to get
people excited about
investing in that market.
So the way to move
that to the next level
was to say, OK, if we could take
technology that was not readily
available 5 or 10 years ago and
bring that into this product
so that we could lower the
cost and improve the usability,
does that give us
access to a market that
doesn't exist before?
And none of those pieces
would've worked by themselves.
And in fact, had
any one of them not
been there the whole principle
wouldn't have come together.
All those pieces had to
be there at the same time.
So this isn't a
company that I think
could have been realistically
started 5 or 10 years ago,
but it is the confluence of the
low-cost sensors, of the cloud,
of the ability to bring
meaningful computing resources
to bear without having
to put them locally
on board the machine that
made this all possible.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: And
with the recent advances
you're really
creating this market,
you're planting the
seeds so that it
can develop in new and
unpredictable ways as well.
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
One of the questions
that I get a lot,
especially from press and
journalists, is who is it,
who bought this thing, or
who is your target market?
And I always am embarrassed by
this because the honest answer
is before we started we said
here are a bunch of markets
that we know are interested but
we don't know how interested.
So there's educators who
are buying 3D printers
to go use with their kids.
And we think this is
a more compelling.
It's faster and the
product is more beautiful.
There are engineers
who are using
these for prototypes
and fixturing
and that sort of thing, and
for first generation product
design.
There are scrapbookers who are
using tools to go and create
beautiful crafts.
There are leather workers, and
woodworkers, and Etsy folk,
and there's all these.
And we're like, we know
there's interest in all of them
but we don't know
the one who's going
to get really excited
about it and bring us home.
And what we found was it
was kind of all of them.
That was the big surprise
of the crowdfunding campaign
is there wasn't one group
that stepped up and provided
the bulk of the orders.
It's this incredibly
diverse set of users
who see this as a tool that
would help them do what it was
that they wanted to do anyway.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So you
touched on something.
And I recently went and toured
a school, a K through 12 school,
and looked at their
computing lab.
And they had a MakerBot,
they had a CNC machine.
It was a very nice school.
But how does this
actually change
how kids approach technology?
Like how does this personal
fabrication revolution,
in a way, change the
youth who is growing up
to be the next technologist?
DAN SHAPIRO: So when I was 7--
my parents are both professors.
My dad was a professor
of CS and my mom's
a professor of speech
and communications.
And they got into
an argument about
whether or not I
should own a computer.
And my mom won so
I got the computer.
My dad, the CS
professor, thought
this doesn't makes
sense for a kid.
So they spent, as best I can
tell, it was about $2,500
in today's dollars to buy a
Commodore 64 and a disk drive.
And when I was 7, I remember
sitting on my dad's knee,
I had just seen the musical
Joseph and the Technicolor
Dreamcoat, and stringing
together AND statements to go
make a choose-your-own-adventure
type game around the story
of the musical that
we'd just seen.
So, fast forward.
I have twins, boy and a girl.
They're both 7 now.
And they came home
from school-- this
is early on in Glowforge's
existence-- they came home
and they said tomorrow we're
having Wild West day at school.
We need sheriff's badges.
And so they sat down and they
drew their sheriff's badges.
And I went over to early,
early, early version
and cut and engraved,
and this and that.
Put a magnet on the back and
they wore them to school.
And this has been pretty
typical of the interactions that
have been happening
for months prior.
And my wife turned
to me and said,
have you noticed
the kids are asking
us to make things for them more
often than buy things for them?
And that was the
like, oh my gosh,
like this is the Commodore 64
that I had when I was a kid.
This is a new way
the world works,
which is there's a revolution
30 years ago that when
you thought of an
idea you could realize
it yourself in software.
And now we're reaching
another revolution
where when you have an
idea you can realize
it yourself in hardware.
And that's something
I can't wait
to see what kids who grow
up assuming fabrication
capabilities, the same
way that I grew up
assuming computing
capabilities, to see
what they do with the world.
Absolutely.
And on the more
grown up front, I
know I've been having a lot
of these conversations where
a lot of us who
work in technology
deal so much with the
intangible that we--
it's flowery language-- but
we yearn for the physical,
to interact with the
world on a tactile level.
And Glowforge is part of the
way that we can get that back
into our lives.
It's really exciting.
DAN SHAPIRO: I spent
years building up
a wood shop in the
basement so that I
would have a way to go
actually make physical things.
And after years of kind of
getting the hang of everything
I talked to a friend
and he was like,
oh, I made this cool wallet
because I do leather crafting.
And I was like, [SIGHS].
If I would've changed
materials, that
is thousands of
dollars and years more,
and I wish there
was some way that I
had a tool that let
me work across all
these interesting materials.
This is years before Glowforge.
When the twins were
born, I no longer
had time to go into the shop,
set up everything, set up
all the jigs, do some
work, vacuum everything up.
So I started building
RC airplanes and drones,
and flying stuff I got.
Because I'd go in and tinker
for 20 minutes and go out,
plus going to the park
with babies is fun.
So I'd fly things and
they'd kind of stare.
And I still had that
outlet of physical stuff.
The thing that's never existed
before in the world as best
I can tell is a
tool that actually
lets you realize
a creative vision
across multiple materials.
You could be a
furniture maker, you
can be a woodworker, you can
be a paper crafter, leather.
And every one of
those has always
been a specialty that took
years, if not decades,
to become proficient at.
And so saying, hey, here's one
tool that can give you access
to all of those
and it's up to you
whether you want
to draw to use it,
because you can draw and have
it engraved and carved directly
based on your
drawings; whether you
want to use Adobe Illustrator
or Photoshop, Gimp, Inkscape;
or whether you're
going to use CAD;
or whether you're going to
create designs parametrically.
I mentioned Joe Beda earlier as
doing some really cool software
generated parametric
designs to go create things
that you can then print.
However you want to
express your creativity,
you can bring that to
the table and turn it
into something beautiful.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Just fantastic.
But that also leads
into I think what
has to be a final question.
It went by so rapidly.
What is the favorite thing that
you've made with the Glowforge?
DAN SHAPIRO: Gosh.
Just because there have been
so many crazy stories about it,
there's a board-- and I've had
so many wonderful experiences
with it.
There's a board for the
game Settlers of Catan,
for those of you
who are familiar.
Yeah.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
Some nods out there.
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
So I bought online-- because
I was a terrible artist--
I bought some artwork.
And it was you can go print one
of these for yourself for $29.
So I bought the artwork,
did it, printed a game,
had it in the office.
"Wired" came by, took a picture
of it, which I hadn't realized.
The picture wound
up in the article
and I went, oh, that's not cool.
Like we don't really
have permission
to put that artwork in
there and we definitely
don't permission
from Mayfair Games.
And then somebody
posted it to Reddit
and it wound up on the
front page of Reddit.
Just the giant
picture of Settlers
of Catan, not the article.
And so I immediately started
calling everybody I knew.
And it got a hold of, I
think it was Guido Teuber,
the son of the creator Klaus.
I may have that backwards.
And I explained what happened.
I said, would it be OK if
we used Settlers of Catan
in these pictures.
I'm so sorry this happened.
And he said absolutely
not, unless you
put water tiles on there.
Catan's an island.
What are you doing?
There's no water.
And I was like, yes, sir.
Right on it, sir.
So we brought in this
amazing illustrator.
She actually worked
professionally
as a program manager
and then retired
to go illustrate coloring
books for grown ups, which
I didn't even
realize was a thing,
and it's an amazing thing.
And brought her in for a day.
And so we did this cool video
where she illustrated by hand
with pen on paper this
triple-sized Settlers of Catan
set, scanned those, reduced
them, carved and engraved them
onto all these exotic hardwoods.
And it's awesome because
the wood is beautiful.
So the finish is just you go
at it with some spray shellac
and you're done.
There's not a big painting,
and staining, and all this.
And then turn it into
this gorgeous set.
And I've had more people
ask me if they can buy one.
The great thing is
when we ship Glowforge
is there will be
tens of thousands
of people who can go print
one of those and make it.
Sorry, I had to.
It's my favorite.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: And you know,
I actually saw that on Reddit
and I didn't even
make the connection
until, embarrassingly,
quite a bit later.
And it was gorgeous.
DAN SHAPIRO: Thank you.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Top post.
Thank you so much for
coming and talking to, Dan.
And I think that's
all she wrote today.
DAN SHAPIRO: Thank you so much.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Yeah
DAN SHAPIRO: I really
appreciate being here.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]